the Border Patrol faces a deepening
mystery surrounding the death of one
agent and serious injuries to another
agent Rogelio Martinez died on Sunday
from injuries he sustained in the line
of duty both agents were found late
Saturday in a culvert near Van Horne
Texas that's not far from the Mexico
border David Beck knows in the hospital
in El Paso where the injured officer is
an intensive care this morning David
good morning Gail good morning the
surviving Border Patrol agent is in
stable condition but apparently doesn't
remember anything about what happened
the FBI is always brought in to
investigate when it suspects that a
federal law enforcement officer has been
victimized they are investigating here
but in a statement put out last night
the FBI did not mention the word attack
or assault to describe what happened and
you should know that within the last 48
hours there was an email circulated
within the Border Patrol
that said it's unclear whether or not
the agents were attacked or whether or
not they were injured in a fall agent
Rogelio Martinez and his partners wounds
were extensive broken bones major head
trauma Martinez had injuries to his
chest collarbone and ribs the Border
Patrol agents union believes they were
victims of a stoning it is consistent
with having been assaulted with with
possibly rocks that's the only thing
they can think of there was nothing else
there on the scene the FBI says the
agents were found around 11:20 Saturday
night in a culvert near Interstate 10
outside of the town of Van Horne earlier
that night a law enforcement source
tells CBS News Martinez radioed in that
he was getting out of his vehicle and
following a trail of possible footprints
in the dirt he was later found
unconscious and bleeding from the head
Martinez apparently had not drawn his
weapon he was a dedicated agent that
went out there to do his job and he did
not make it home the agents were
airlifted to a hospital in El Paso where
Martinez died from his injuries on
Monday President Trump offered his
sympathies to the agents families and
renewed his call for a border wall we
have to stop the massive drug flow from
boring in and my respect to the families
that were so badly hurt because they
were devastated Emory Crawford is agent
Martinez his longtime friend is all he
want to do is
help people and help the world and try
to make a difference he would be the
type of guy give his shirt off his back
and wouldn't ask for anything in
response the area where the agents were
found is known to be a route used by
drug smugglers the FBI is supposed to
hold a news conference later today if
that happens we will be there and even
though exactly what happened is a
mystery nor we can tell you that the
governor of Texas has authorized a
twenty thousand dollar reward for anyone
who comes forward with information that
leads to an arrest and a conviction in
this case alright David thank you